[Musique]
http de poing sache lâche bonjour
bienvenue dans fast food le journaux des
réseaux social aujourd'hui au sommaire
de cette édition un dossier spécial
consacré aux filtres am stram gram du
moment et puis nous recevrons magic
virgin mais tout de suite on commence
avec le truite de la semaine il est
signé terry bouboule qui nous dit mdr
lol ma soeur est tombé dans les
escaliers suivi quelques minutes plus
tard du truite la [__] elle a cassé ma
psp sans transition c'est un magicien à
ce book que vous vous souvenez très
certainement de son pittoresque que
numéro du lapin qui sort du chapeau en
plusieurs images donc nous recevons
magic virgile virgile bonjour bonjour je
suis très content d'être là et bien ça
fait moins une personne heureuse virgile
de votre nouveau tour qu'est ce que
c'est je fais disparaître des pages
internet alors par exemple prend une
page au hasard par exemple cette page le
bon gros à la hâte en seo à brac alors
là d'accord c'est tout oui cette page
mais plus disponible si manger autre
chose
regardez cette fois tout alors chercher
je ne comprends pas où sont les pièces
d'échecs ne va pas il joue en mode sans
échec alors à quel talent merci virgile
culture maintenant une exposition qui se
tient sur am stram gram flirte avec les
filtres de l'artiste peintre ibrahim
celui ci qui sont mauvais jeunot
s'infiltre dans les filtres au fil des
fils et qui au regard des filtres le
filtre bien connu dit sierra x pro le
rise mais aussi le kitty kitty le ninja
art le sanex et la dernière création
d'ibrahim que voici
alors pour parler de ce dernier fils
très bien nous avons la chance de
recevoir l'artiste
ibrahim alors ibrahim tout vous est
venue l'idée de ce nouveau filtre
d'accord mais en fait comment s'appelle
ce nouveau filtre la mer noire un très
bien et elle en votre atelier où est-ce
qu'on peut le trouver
la mer noire très bien merci beaucoup
ibrahim et bien c'est la fable ii se
fasse plus
des réseaux social de m'avoue retrouver
guillaume pétait à 13h pour le journal
s'il retrouve sur le lean et son mot de
passe
et d'ici là n'oubliez pas de ff asplund
[__] je n'ai dit la mer noire
[Musique]